we really didn't want this to be a
concept of uh
um this is the cool gadgets that you you
just
buy or another another gadget we wanted
this to be tied into something people
care about
[Music]
danielle thank you so much for joining
me on 20 minute leaders
thank you for having me so good to have
you where are you calling from right now
uh tel aviv television how's everything
with the quarantine and we code 19
it's uh it seems reasonable now actually
it's uh we're we're starting to see the
end and
uh people are more outside and yeah
i'm fairly optimistic around that at the
moment
fantastic you know this interview is
going to be published in a few weeks
so i'm always curious to see how the
state of
during the interview time and then what
actually happens once it's published so
yeah let's hope that everything is open
by then and everything's
everything's wonderful and danielle
you're working on one of the one of the
coolest companies that i know and that's
because i'm
a you know i'm a fitness and healthy
sort of fanatic myself i used to be so
passionate about what i put in my body
and and how i and how i treat myself and
now with the quarantine i've been
indulging in a little
bit more pizza than i should uh but
all of us danielle you know before we
get into lumen
give me a brief round of everything
you've learned up to now because you you
you're a seasoned entrepreneur you've
had a lot of experience before coming to
lumen
and then let's dive into this incredible
device that you've
created okay okay so i'll try to be
brief around that so
i'm um i've been entrepreneur for the
past
uh 16 years so this is lumen is
my our third company i'll talk about my
founders
in a second uh
but um kind of my professional life this
is almost all i did
before that boy scouts kid in the boy
scouts uh
a lot of people interaction and so forth
uh
and then the navy as a navy officer
well uh so that's uh i think
kind of gave me a certain skill sets to
let's say work pretty well with people
yeah but uh but nothing professional
really to
to dive into and i think i became a good
learner around that
sure sure uh those periods of time but
that's uh
that's it so uh my journey began uh very
naively in 2005.
i set next to uh the first day of school
in university in idc and herzeglia
i sat next to my uh my founder today i
partnered uh
a lot of for a lot of time uh we sat
next to each other
his name is duo and um very naively we
started
talking about doing something on the
internet and uh we built something
we built a product uh we found our
our uh our missing link the technical
guy
who was was our cto in all companies and
still is
avi and uh we built kind of a search
engine to
uh a very visual
one that helps people kind of browse
through
the top websites in every category that
was the first
initiative we made every mistake
possible
in the book we we built a product never
launched it for two and a half years
while tweaking it and improving it no
one ever
experienced that um and then we launched
it at techcrunch50
and at the time we launched it uh we
decided that no one will actually use
that engine there is a better one out
there um
and we killed it and immediately got
start pitching something else
basically in the second day of the
conference we started pitching something
completely different
uh and that thing was a tool for
websites to
and publishers to integrate apps into
some services into their yep
platforms so and that was our second
company basically that was libya
uh and webia was kind of a fairytale
story uh
two and a half years raised about 2.5
million dollars eventually sold it to
another company another israeli company
called conduit
yep um and stayed there for two and a
half years
and then uh the three of us left and
started based basically three months
later
started working on lumen so daniel you
actually went with your two co-founders
throughout this whole entrepreneurial
gender for 15 years which is also it's
not that common
and you know a lot of so i actually saw
that
from the top reasons why companies fail
one of the top reasons is that founders
have a dispute at some point
and and they part ways uh but you have
an experience here
do you think that that's sort of like
the fact that you were all in the army
not necessarily together but you all
went through these this camaraderie
experience and you learn what it takes
to work with people even if you don't
necessarily see eye to eye on everything
um i'm i'm not sure it's the army i
think it's the type of personas you work
with and not necessarily
maybe i mean yes the army gets uh maybe
gives you some skills around that but
you can you can take it from a lot of
places and it's mainly the people you
choose
to work and to be honest it's also it's
a process right we were
oh yeah and we all of us had a lot of
ego on the table when we started working
together and everything was much much
harder
um and yes we were fortunate to continue
together
uh but first for lumen what we did was
even more uh
was more dangerous it's basically lumen
was incubated in my house so my spouse
mikhail
and her twin sister marav they it's
basically their baby so they are the
science nutrition
physiology everything's smart behind
what we do um
i uh fell in love with the concept the
concept of
measuring and understanding something
that really happens in my body that
potentially will have an impact on
on the way i train on the food i eat and
on my health in the future and i was
fascinated by that and i'm fortunate to
have a very good teacher
uh every evening on the couch explaining
to me the science i love it ideology
works and everything and
and somehow i don't know how i got my my
co-founders law and avi to
to join into this uh journey i know how
i
sold them a a a very like a very big lie
in a sense i told them this and it's
going to be a breeze it's hardware but
we
get the sensors we get design we do a
kickstarter after year
we have a product out there that was
and it only took us six years to get the
product out eventually uh but we did
um i love it that was uh
i love that story so so where is lumen
right now so at this
so may 2020 what's happening with lumens
the lumens started in 2014 but actually
in a way lumen is really starting now uh
we launched the product to our backers
who backed us on indiegogo um
10 000 of them in 2018 yeah ten thousand
of them in two
in kind of mid late 2018. wow we
delivered the product
uh it took us a lot of time but we
delivered uh the product
in uh in january most of the products
got to
customers in january and now we're
actually feeding from their feedback
continuously improving the product and
very soon in
about two weeks time we're going to kind
of publicly launch
what we're doing after we get some
feedback and we have got more inventory
to uh
to sell so yeah lumen is uh
it's the middle of the journey but for
the people outside of the company in a
way it's just the start just the
beginning oh
oh i'm sure so so first of all indiegogo
i don't get to meet many people that
have launched
such successful campaigns on indiegogo i
mean 10 000 units sold
that's a lot of confidence and a product
that hasn't been
launched yet what was that experience
like going on
on crowdfunding and trying to get the
public to really buy into this idea
of of this hardware that's going to help
you gain control
over what you put into your body yeah it
was
it was fascinating because um you know
we've been
pitching this concept and we've actually
been uh testing it with prototypes like
uh in
uh since 2017 but still to
for someone to take money out of the
pocket and pay for something
for for a device and really engage with
it
that was uh you really need to
understand how you're going to sell this
and why would people
buy it and we really didn't want this to
be a concept of
this is the cool gadgets that you you
just buy or another
another gadget we wanted this to be tied
into something people care about
and nutrition is something people are
deeply passionate about
there is a community of people who are
obsessed about it
for for different reasons working out
losing weight
um and so we took a shot at this
uh basically not positioning this as a
device that
can do thousands of things but actually
more capturing and showing you
if lumen is in your hands how can you
use it how
what's the value for you and i think
as opposed to many other campaigns that
are
basically showcasing technology
uh we were a lot more focused on the
experience and we kind of
knew that the experience we're offering
is something that people will actually
be using and succeeding with so
that's i think a theme too that's
that is pretty solid to start to work on
a campaign with
um to be honest i didn't do a lot in the
campaign it's
also finding the people who are uh
talented around that and
my my partner always led let this calm
concept almost completely alone with a
very
selective few and he did a phenomenal
job
definitely definitely so give me you
know in a few sentences
what what am i experiencing when i hold
lumen in my hands and trust me i'm gonna
be holding lumen in my hands
okay sooner or later okay so yes this is
this is lumen it's
a very small device that you can carry
with you or
just put in your stand and you breathe
to this in the morning
um it's not normal breath you inhale air
through it and everything is guided
through a nap
you hold the air in your lungs for 10
seconds and you exhale
and what lumen does is is basically
sampling the co2 content of your breath
and through that it basically reflects
to you whether you're
currently using fats or carbs for fuel
in real time
um and it changes right our body can use
fats and carbs and those are two
different fuels for
probably different goals in a sense but
what you want to be doing if if you're
waking up in the morning
on a fasted state you want your body to
be using fats
because night time is the time for the
body to transition to fat burn
in a sense so that's the first moment in
the day that
you can get a sense of control of really
what's happening
but what happened yesterday have you
been eating too much you ate too late
you drank alcohol in the evening uh
stress
sleep deprivation all of those are
preventing you basically from
from getting into uh um
from from getting into fat burn in the
morning but then what do i do with this
information so let's say i get this
information okay yeah fine so i'm
burning
carbs i'm not burning fat what do i do
now
so what lumen provides you with is
is kind of actionable insights on what
you should be doing
so you get a nutrition plan for today
what you should be eating you should
follow that
um it's insightful around workouts and
it's insightful around
how much carbs proteins and fats you
should have and it actually
uh gradually becomes more and more
actionable
the way we design the product and once
you follow that
you'll measure again the next morning
and you start seeing the change
uh in a way there is a learning
experience in that journey
of self-exploration and it teaches you
what's work what works for you
which not necessarily will be the thing
that will work for someone else
so and how how quickly will i see this
change
and how quickly will i see the progress
that i'm making towards my let's say my
goal is to burn more fat so how quickly
will i
i notice this change it's um
it really depends on how on on you in a
sense people who are
uh insulin resistance or uh
having sudden resist since who are
prediabetic
will probably take a bit longer to see
the impact but
generally healthy people it's a matter
of day wow
following a nutrition plan and seeing
that um
and and it's an interesting feedback
loop because you can mess it up very
easily
okay one night of uh playing poker
eating pizza with friends
um you wake up on a on a carburetor very
easily
which is okay right it's uh it's it's
part of life
but you want to have the tool that kind
of guides you or the compass that
gives you direction when you're when
you're good when the
things you did are impactful or when
it's not when you can
get back to back on track basically
definitely so you know
two questions here because uh changing
human behavior
and changing consumer behavior is
difficult it's almost impossible a
i had the pleasure of working with dan
ariely at irrational labs
a few years ago and and our research and
our work was centered around
how can we think of consumer behavior on
on technological products and guide for
different
behaviors based on what we're doing and
part of dan's
premise is that you know we are
irrational beings we it's very hard for
us to change
our behavior but it's very easy for it's
much easier for us to change our
environment
which will force us to change our
behavior so how do you
how do you perceive users adhering to
this nutrition plan and changing their
behavior as a result of seeing
this these results on an app is that
something that you really think is going
to happen
or have you been saying that it's
happening we're already seeing it's
happening
but it's a it's a process of designing
so the device is really only the first
phase right the the experience that the
user go through in terms of insights and
what should he do about it as you
as you said rightfully it's happening in
the app right and that journey is really
happening through content in the app
sure um i can give you an example
exactly pointing to the point
that you're raising uh when we launched
this or
gave it to beta users in the early
batches we told them
you can measure in the morning and
before before lunch and after lunch
before workout
after work workout we gave them tons of
opportunities to measure and understand
stuff
um and it was a bit overwhelming to them
and then what we did
is say what is the ritual the one ritual
we need to nurture
that will become maybe the default we
have
basically we have a potential to capture
a moment of the user's day when is that
going to be
and how how much value we can focus on
that moment
and that moment is morning time we we
find that morning time at fasting
there is something um there is a it's a
it's a mindful moment that you can take
for yourself
uh and people can get used to it
basically like rushing their teeth right
behavioral change is hard but people are
relatively okay with brushing their
teeth i hope
um and so i think wellness rituals
have a potential to to make an impact
into and to become habits
if if there is a feedback loop right
it's it's
it's easier to some extent if you can
measure something
that gives you a reflection of what's
happening and where you're going you're
where you're heading oh no totally and
you know so that and and i think that
goes back to a lot of research by
nereo and habit formation and atomic
habits
uh that i read recently about how do you
do these incremental steps
and one of the most important parts of
habit formation really is this idea that
you have this quick feedback loop
and you can see this you know very
incremental small progress
every day because a lot of people who
are let's say are trying to lose weight
which i guess is a very common use case
for people who want to use lumen they if
they don't
see their weight drop within a day or
two it becomes very hard to
continue this ritual but if you can
guide them on
a daily basis of okay you've you've now
transitioned a little bit more towards
the fat burning zone that that makes
sense is something that could be very
beneficial
yeah that's that's true and i can say
that in the past six years we struggled
a lot about
weight loss in general right because
what happens when weight loss
when you succeed let's say it works and
you lose a couple of pounds
and and so why will you use lumen
in a sense and that's uh so and what's
the value of that ritual
so what we focus on um is really about
metabolic flexibility
and metabolic health and this is a
constant evolution of your body our
metabolism changes
on a daily basis but also really like
being in shape and out of shape
right if you run every day you're in
shape if you stop running for a week
you're you're a bit out of shape you're
not completely out of shape but you're
trailing into this
the same happens with our metabolic
flexibility
or metabolic health our ability to use
carbs or fats as
fuel as they're available or not
available
uh fats from our own stores and
and that is something that never dies in
a way that's something that you can
constantly improve
and the nutrition journey people uh take
upon themselves
is is one that is dynamically changing
they start to work out
their metabolism changes they they fly
now no one flies but they fly and they
get
jet lit right they so
they go on a vacation um so in a sense
that's uh that's how we see uh
the future even if people come to lose
weight what we get them hooked on
eventually is metabolic health which is
something sustainable
i love it okay so the the second it
comes on on amazon or wherever you're
selling it
please let me know so i can be one of
the first people to purchase it
it sounds incredible and as a person who
i i'm very dedicated to my health and
working out and
and and doing a lot of these a lot of
these research on my own
uh it's definitely something that we
need and it's something that i would
find so useful because
that unknown and that feeling of control
that you don't really feel like you have
over your body
throughout your life i think that's
something that's that's really really
wonderful
and daniel before we go and i can't
believe 20 minutes are almost over
because i have so many questions
i want to ask you the most important
question uh three words
that you would best describe yourself or
that one of your co-founders would
describe you as
so um i'll be honest i thought about it
because that's a tough question i think
it's a good one though it's the hardest
question
it's the hardest question uh so i think
uh optimistic would be one um i'm
definitely optimistic in everything else
yours is an entrepreneur daniel come on
yeah yeah
you have to be optimistic and in doing
some stuff that are
really off the trend um and you know
wellness is a trend but hardware
no one will invest in hardware
especially the early stages
it's it's really hard to build a company
that
is doing consumer behavioral changes you
claim
hardware and so forth so optimistic is
one
um i'm a learner i love it i love
i look at every experience i'm going
through as
a learning phase if it's the dynamics
with the team or if it's
understanding co2 and co2 sensors and so
forth and the last one is
uh is a leader but it's an aspiration so
i
aspire to be a good leader but not good
leader for the community good leader for
my team in a sense so
this is my my focus and i hope i'm i'm
on a trajectory to do a good job there
danielle thank you so much and and thank
you
for everything it sounds amazing thank
you cheers
you